alors l'idée de réunir des artistes dans
cette oeuvre collective mais venir un
petit peu dans les jours qui ont suivi
l'annoncé du confinement est généralisée
voilà c'était une période où la peine
conscient qu'il était prévu qu'il
annulait chaque jour les nouvelles
devenait un peu un peu plus un peu
triste un coin du sri est ce que la
musique pour les chanteurs les musiciens
et les compositeurs voilà c'est une
période de l'ondé d'un roman qui
s'annonçait et pour conjurer le sort et
pour se dire qu'au final rien à lui nous
empêcher en fait de faire ce qu'on aime
de la musique
jewil dévoila de fair morceau
participatif j'envoyais quelques notes
de guitare aptn potes musiciens alors
dix ans de s'enregistrer par dessus et
déjà quelque chose ce qu'ils voulaient
et de me renvoyer et sans jamais
entendre que les autres proposé à la
banque tout le monde a écouté que la
guitare vous voyez et avec toutes ces
pistes audio j'ai réussi à faire-- un
morceau original avec le complot de tout
le monde
et voilà il fallait a fait du bien à
tous je crois parce que tu as nous
montrer que même si nous étions tous
dans notre coin
on était ensemble quoi et que je vois là
était tout ça n'allait pas arrêter la
créativité la musique
je suis très content d'avoir cette
expérience je pense que on va faire
d'autres sûrement
j'étais déjà que quand tout ça sera fini
j'aurais bien aimé en faire avec tout le
monde dehors et voilà mais je suis très
content de la cayrié les athlètes
apparemment